I'm very pleased to be here for another
special conversation this time with my
friend colleague and former classmate
Matt flam matt is among many other
things a specialist in the thought the
life and the works of George Santayana
very active in the the santiana society
and you've got some some works on him
too right as well so maybe we'll talk
about that but you know Santa Jana is a
philosopher I don't think it's very well
known so I wanted to take the
opportunity while I have somebody here
who really does know how to to make the
case why he might be interesting to you
the viewers and and why he's worth
reading mulling over studying why there
could be in fact a Asante out of society
hopefully we'll talk a little bit about
about that so one place to begin is
people probably have not read Southie
Anna where should they start if they're
going to pick one work or essay to begin
with those who cannot remember the past
are condemned to repeat it is the most
famous quote of Santa Anna's that has
passed along and yeah very few people
who use that quote there paraphrase it
know that it's even santiana and that's
fine you know that's true
a lot of thinkers but but that
particular quote comes from under the
philosophical source series that he
wrote that from when she became first
most famous called the life of Reason
and well we've talked about this
elsewhere I you know jumping off points
for a figure like Santana are difficult
because it really depends on where
you're coming from and for me it was
skepticism and animal faith that was the
first one for me as well yeah
Jenny which I only happen to read
because I picked it up at a used
bookstore and I heard Santana was
somebody to check out yeah from being at
SIU yeah well and honestly
biographically towards my sort of
philosophical you know development I
some Tana was the reason I got into
philosophy I was a young undergraduate
student I was reading I took my first
lawsuit my second philosophy class at
that time and I'd read de cartes
meditations and I'd read
the things that I was really sort of
fired up about this stuff about which I
was only starting to become aware yeah
and then I read that text and there was
something about it it just made sense to
me he was he was rien gauging
cartesianism and if anyone who's read
skepticism and animal faith it's an
introduction to his ontological realms
of being the larger work that he wrote
in his later service publishing life but
the book is in itself a really rich
engagement with the Cartesian sort of
approach and it's it's he intends it as
a kind of subversion of it ultimately
you know but but it just was so powerful
to me and it said for me and in the
young stage of my reading of Descartes I
remember thinking exactly the thoughts
of this is what I yeah this is what
problem I had with Descartes too you
know that's sort of the thought I had
won everything now that then of course
led to having to you know engage with
all kinds of things because some Tianna
as a thinker this is one of the things
that makes him something unique he kind
of requires you to engage with the whole
history philosophy I mean santiana is
rooted in Platonism a big part of his
thinking he was a great great student of
Plato he studied under Paulson in
Germany who a great scholar teacher of
Plato so knew his Plato he knew his
Aristotle very well and from that basis
then provides any also engaged with the
moderns in a very nerdy place so so very
broad-minded a philosophical upbringing
himself that then led to a very original
philosophic outlook of its own he's a
materialist which is not a very popular
word and it has weird connotations and
there's others varieties of materialist
depending on what you consider matter
too consistent yeah yeah and if it makes
sense to philosophical listeners I would
characterize it as a non reductive
material yeah yeah he's really trying to
reconcile what we think of the spiritual
life with with our material existence
and and that's maybe a straightforward
way of thinking about what he's really
about you know santiana believes there
is something like a spiritual life and
he thinks it is synonymous with whatever
we are in terms of our consciousness
yeah so I mean this is a bit of a
digression
we'll come back two more recommendations
is that why although not religious
himself he takes religion seriously
looking at it almost in his you know in
a continuity with the aesthetic and and
other higher drives of the human being
most certainly yeah and you know having
been raised Catholic although his his
father and mother differed in their own
religious alliances significantly and as
many I think people who come from
religious settings that's very often the
case yeah parents well mixed marriages
they call them yeah and but that
certainly had a formative influence on
it but Santana as a young person was
very very idealistic and very
religiously inclined almost to a point
where I mean you eat early on he may
have been destined for the priesthood
even yeah but he he eventually just
migrated towards this life of this
intellectual life he also had early
aspirations to be an architect which is
a side footnote shows that how
aesthetically inclined he wasn't you
know and but he to this point he he was
he he was easy collected he's he his
relation to religion was very sort of
like interesting he wrote the luminously
I mean yes is a book called Platonism
and the spiritual life which is a
beautiful appreciation of the spiritual
life in connection with the tradition of
Platonism and then another book called
the idea of Christ and the Gospels which
shows an unbelievable literacy in the
history of Christian religion and an
appreciation for its contributions to
culture so santiana saw it in a kind of
a cultural way he sees a religion as a
kind of vital source of sustenance in a
cultural way I mean do you think that's
similar with Royce then yes you know he
was connected with yeah his teacher at
Harvard no question I think that
Santiago probably imbibed something of
this fungoides directly although another
thing that needs to be written by
somebody smarter than me I wish somebody
like Randy action would think about this
because he's so first in Royce and only
a little bit touched on something I
think he's suspicious of them but I'd
love to see something like Randy calm
relationship and then also you know talk
about the contrast because Royce
famously had the prophecy of santiana
and santiana relates this in the hell LP
volume on his thought he says that it
was Royce who first had the you know
kind of his finger on what my philosophy
was really about at the earliest stages
of my months being a student under Royce
he did his dissertation on doors he said
that it sounds like what's fundamental
to your philosophy is the separation
between essence and existence and sort
of capping off yeah intimidating
categories but they become categories in
his ontological system but some Tina
says that because at that time when he
was a student under Royce he wanted to
write on Schopenhauer and he said well
that would be ok but it's not
appropriate for you know a proper
dissertation so once you write on Luksa
remember lotsa ya my German
pronunciation is terrible but so any
wrote a fine dissertation on that Benny
the voice of course was satisfied with
it but it's an interesting moment
because you can tell that this has some
kind of its kind of the DNA of something
on this early development you can tell
that boys had a big impact on his early
formative development for sure it's also
kind of funny because I mean who read
looks up today compared right yeah yeah
I have that just cool kind of stuff when
we had our own versions of it at our
graduate school - yeah so now I wrote on
santiana in my graduate school for my
prelim exams as we talked about in
another discussion but yeah so he's an
eclectic figure he's known but not known
yeah well let's talk about the where he
fits in in American philosophy and I
think a lot of a lot of viewers don't
really know this because they look at
the current academic configuration where
American philosophy and we're talking
about the continent is really dominated
by analytic philosophy but that's
something that developed in the 1950s
onward and almost sort of a cultural
imperialism took place you know in terms
of that zone but before that there was
something that we call classical
American philosophy reaching all the way
back to you know people like Jonathan
Edwards and the transcendentalist
and then reaching forward to people like
like John Dewey where it is santiana
fit into that and then he's an outsider
in a way but he's also clearly in the
stream of American philosophy right
absolutely absolutely so the tradition
of naturalism you know among the isms we
associate with American philosophy of
course the first most is pragmatism but
thanks to Dewey and James and so on but
naturalism is a broader kind of you know
tradition we can call it that within the
classical American philosophic tradition
he belongs square in that and in fact so
there was a volume put out in I should
know the decade but I don't offhand but
there's a volume on critical realism
that came out that had santiana featured
in there and it was against his own
wishes to be in there he he was invited
and he said oh sure whatever you know
that oh gosh why am I forgetting all
that because I'm being asked to remember
that's why but give me a second sure so
that he was included in the volume and
but the reason he objected to it was
this tone realism right he he he saw the
affinities and he certainly understood
why you know so-called critical realists
were you know convinced that somebody
like santiana would be you know among
their number yeah santiana as a
professed self professed materialist he
believed that existence in the realm of
existence of the you know later call
that i guess is is you know is the only
you know it's the source and cause of
all there is and he thinks that he's
certainly he's not Plato as I said
everything is friendly deployed is not a
transcendental thinker himself he
believes that he's closer as a matter of
fact at the ancient stoic it's perhaps
yeah thinking that spiritual reality is
in some way material yeah or I mean
there have been other people along the
way as well I mean we can think of
Hegel's somebody like that there's some
interesting you know connections between
Santi and Hegel his early life of Reason
series he thought it was tainted with
Hegelian ism which is I think an
overstatement he just in his own mind I
think he
thought he was too influenced by Hegel
but now it's gotten Fitch you had the
same criticism of his you know birth of
tragedy well I suppose if you're gonna
you're gonna pick somebody to be
contaminated by evil you know yeah not
be a bad guy yeah so you know you know
something he I think that too you're
kind of earlier part of your question so
the American tradition in a classical
sense we think of CS purse and as a kind
of a bookending figure but going back
before first certainly Jonathan Edwards
Emerson Thoreau and so on but purse is
kind of the beginning of a particular
strain in American philosophy and it
becomes pragmatism it becomes the most
sort of world recognized way of writing
about American philosophy for a lot of
people probably the only thing that they
associate with America's actors
specially Europeans you know you talk to
if they know anything about America
philosophy oh yeah pragmatism John Dewey
and James and first they might know but
yeah but sometime not so much and in
fact when you see the collections of
American philosophy he's not always
included he yeah sometimes it's mostly
is I think it depends mostly on how
comprehensive the collection is going to
be if it's gonna be something that's you
know almost like it just a textbook for
for maybe non majors it probably won't
happen yeah yeah and so and he himself
but he himself nonetheless insisted on
being categorized as an American
philosopher he was intellectually bred
certainly in America he wrote in English
because he not only because he mastered
it but even as Bertrand Russell of all
people complements them you know he he's
kind of become he's become a he's the
greatest writer in English in America in
the American tradition you know I mean
somebody like Bertrand Russell
complimenting him for his English
writing shows why he never really
straight from that he he just was he was
obviously an artistically inclined
person to begin with and already had a
poetic sensibility yeah so I think his
facility with language and his
transition to English was was kind of
seamless and then he he never strayed
from that he and moreover I think he
would have said it was more honest
moments I think he
that he he really never he formed his
central philosophic positions out of the
American sensibility of the American
tradition I think he would admit that he
doesn't overtly he doesn't directly
admit that native writings yes close to
admitting it but I think in his more
lost moments he would have to confess
that I mean he was you know again he's a
student of James and Royce yeah I mean
in a certain sense to be part of the
American tradition already means to have
these other connections to Britain and
to European culture you mentioned that
he does you know
he's not just reading German and
philosophy which I think everybody in
American philosophy was doing at the
time that he studied and you know
there's a lot of confluences I know
James more that in this in this respect
mostly actually from his connection with
French writers who he was corresponding
with so I imagine there must been
something quite similar with Santa Anna
absolutely there's actually si you are
our PhD institution they had at one time
and I'm not sure they still do but they
had in their special collections they
had some see on this copy of William
James's principles of psychology Oh
which James was reading in manuscript
for the course of Santana was taking
with James so imagine that taking
William James
whatever the title that he's reading
from his manuscript principles of
psychology well years later Santi Ana
when he left America in fact he
bequeathed his book I should know who
offhand I think I did at one time and
I'll think of that again but I'm not
trying to but he now the book ended up
becoming he just sort of said who wants
this and and it was bequeath and
eventually ended up at Carbondale but it
was I looked at it and it's his copy of
the principles of psychology with all
kinds of marked annotations and
fascinating and there's you know you in
one moment he writes essence in the
margins next to a passage of James so
he's clearly influenced by James there's
no question yeah and and I would say
this I would say his his understanding
of psychology is almost directly I mean
it's it's it's absolutely connected with
wheen of James's thinking and his
underst
of psychology and human behavior the way
he discusses it in various contexts is
absolutely well again James has in
common sort of this was Royce that you'd
brought up sort of non reductive
materialism this notion James you know
fault that the empiricists are not being
empirical enough for for not attending
to enough of a range of human
experiences and wanting to say well if
it can't be measured thinking it what we
nowadays would call a a scientist way
the back of the day they called
positivism taking a positivist attitude
towards it so I think they you know I
mean you see that as something that's
essential to American philosophy or is
that something that kind of falls out of
the picture maybe with Dewey and onward
this kind of radical empiricism so yeah
and that's a good I mean that's the way
James described it and I think that's a
good rubric for all of it you know
empiricism they had thinks that you know
locky and empiricism are human and
empiricism or the empiricism of a you
know positivist Spencer or if they were
looking at Russell it's just is not
cutting it because it doesn't it leaves
a too wide of a swath of our actual
experience yeah absolutely so you know
santiana
the only difference is Santana would say
you know why why why not nature why not
matter you know I think I think his
problem with both James and Dewey
ultimately is he saw them as squinting
in their own ways and maybe make and
maybe that was something that was unfair
of it he has specific essays in which he
engages them pretty deeply at night and
the exchange I don't know if I mentioned
in the previous discussion but yeah the
famous confrontation between John Dewey
and George Santayana happened in 1925 I
believe in the journal philosophy and
santiana famously accused duty of being
a half-hearted naturalist and then do we
respond anybody calling him a broken
back naturalist so it's the sky yeah so
I think those what are those mean what
do they mean by those boy that's at play
like there's been some things written on
and I've tried to ride on it myself I
think Richard Rubin has one of the best
commentaries on it
came up but but what does it mean so you
know santiana
I see it as a lost opportunity first and
foremost just to speak by grass Oh
interest i-i've always thought John do
it was far more charitable for sure and
gracious and open to having a kind of a
connection with something that's auntie
Anna just preempted that but that's kind
of basically pissing do me off really
you know from the very beginning but
with that particular essay in fact which
he insisted on as Larry Hickman who
pointed out to me a couple of times so
you know santiana
insisted on having that go for his
further comment that he had a chance to
actually amend that for our later
publication said do you want to like add
to this after you know do he had as
responsive now I just let that go I
don't care and even says in a letter
like don't bother so he didn't make much
effort let's just say something I didn't
mean to yeah to make connection with you
which is very unfortunate I would argue
that experience in nature by John Dewey
has a lot more in common with skepticism
and animal faith then well either of
those thinkers would care to admit maybe
do me more than something I don't care
dude you know it's interesting so that
brings to mind for me two other sort of
missed opportunities one also from the
20th century stemming from the Christian
philosophy debates that I think you've
work on that took place in France and
the same sort of thing where you know
you've got this long Dalian position
coming from Maurice blown down and
you've got eighteen Joe so another
Jacques Maritain lined up against them
and for three Catholic thinkers who in
the rest of their dealings with
everybody else treated each other
treating other people with the utmost of
charity not just in the sense of sort of
act in and academic way but in showing
the virtue of it they it's almost as if
they deliberately misunderstood each
other's positions so that there could be
a conflict because there were so many
ways in which what they were saying was
complimentary to each other
the other thing that it reminds me of is
the really lost opportunity between
Thomas Hobbes and Rene Descartes and
Paris where Hobbes that you know
Hobson's is one of the he's really he
really is the father of modern and
political philosophy more than say
Machiavelli and I would even argue
argue this I mean a piece that Hobbs
deserves just as much as they cart to be
called one of the fathers of modern
philosophy in terms of epistemology and
metaphysics just as much as Descartes
does and so you got these two really
great minds and how you really wanted to
engage take heart take heart really was
not at all let hobbes gave one of those
sets of objections and the meditations
and that was it yeah the cart was done
with it yeah yeah and so you see these
lost opportunities and putting the
sights you know the examples speaking a
little bit more broadly do you think
that's something that's kind of endemic
to the world of philosophy we
philosophers are not as rational as we
have to be right absolutely I mean I
think there's as much of a human
tendency for philosophy types to to come
to fail to engage each other and yeah
and in an adequate and charitable way as
other people who find themselves to so I
think it's human nature I really do and
I think you know it's not all bad either
like I think what was interesting about
the exchange between Sandtown Duty which
is just a published exchange but didn't
go that didn't go further and do we
wanted it to do wanted it to and it
would have welcomed it going for this is
a temperamental thing definitely and you
know some do you know the unfortunate
side to Santana's personality and I've
always struggled with this in my
otherwise just an admiration of him is
he really was too aloof he lived very
moved from the world he never had kids
yeah he never really had family you
never had a sense of connection to the
world whatsoever and it's kind of
remarkable to me that he lived as long
as he did and as happily as he did
without any of that just because it's
it's kind of rare for a person to be so
disconnected from the world into yet be
yeah well it brings up another
interesting point and I mean we could
think of complaints that could be made
of other thinkers you know like what
could what could thomas aquinas or
Anselm of Canterbury possibly have to
tell us about about long when when they
were you know one was a prior one was a
monk you know what would epictetus
possibly
- tell us about the bellick you know say
management when when he most he ever did
was run a school I you know do you think
that not having had those experiences
precludes you from being able to say
intelligent things about them we don't
want to rule it out entirely right no
and there's a wonderful discussion of
this very thing in dialogue on George
Santayana which happened at the time of
his death and when colleagues friends
acquaintances and students all kind of
gathered in a very informal setting and
had a discussion and they entertained
this very question and the question came
up of you know he was so aloof and I I
wonder if something it wasn't just kind
of sad and and there was speculation
about him being a sad old person dying
in Rome alone yeah and there's absolute
evidence to that effect he got he was
pretty lonely at the end of things I
visited his actual hotel room in the nun
convent in Rome which is very it's very
much intact the balcony where his hotel
room was you could kind of see it yeah
and and it's kind of small and humble
and depressing austere yeah and it was
less austere than I thought I was
picturing something something really
like I guess fancy or something but it's
a hospital yeah you know he spent a good
deal the last part of his life getting
his meals delivered to him and then his
bed you know turned up or whatever and
taking walks around Rome and you know
tearing he would he would only read what
he could carry with him on his walks and
he would like tear out parts of books
and walk with that part that he tore out
and I was very kind of like he was very
he only wanted to take with him what he
could hold in his hands kind of you know
and when he just said he sounds to have
lived and he seems to have lived a
rather solitary and at times probably
lonely and sad like but he was he was
not unaware of this and you see this in
his letters he's self-conscious if he's
self aware of this and he reflects on it
any and he actually he's bittersweet
about it and I think he takes a
disillusioned attitude towards it
ultimately he comes you think there's
something in the way he lived his life
and then perhaps the value that he
placed upon that that's similar to the
solitude that other philosophers or
poets - and
particularly rainer maria rilke thought
was it was necessary for us to to
develop fully as human beings I mean
Rilke products about solitude in almost
metaphysical ways that we need to deepen
it within ourselves we're not really
capable of fully loving somebody until
we've developed within our solitude and
grown love as two solitudes protecting
each other and then Nietzsche talks
about the need for solitude as well and
you know sort of the Stoics yeah I think
this beautiful sentiment and I think
that's absolutely true and maybe for
that reason you know something is not
necessarily to be pitied you know yeah
maybe after all he was developing in
himself a kind of a solitary ability to
to be at home with himself perhaps to
some degree I mean again back to his
homosexuality about which he was the
only illusion in one letter and there's
there's very little there's no overt
evidence of this except through
relationships with the elder Russell
yeah so there's some interesting
biographical stuff there but santiana
never consummated ultimately as it were
he is seeming homosexuality and for that
reason he lived on the fringes of most
of his relationships and it was
perfectly content to do that I mean to
be fair to santiana to on this point he
was incredibly sociable just because he
lived a solitary life he was a very
cheerful person to go visit and he was
very welcoming and he loved visitors and
welcomed them all the time he talked all
the time about it seemed like a visitor
was coming to his door every every month
and he was spending loads of time
travelling around with various of his
associations including his literary
executor well I mean we think that not
having a lot of connections that opens
up the possibility to offer that kind of
hospitality I think so and I think he
may have also compensated for what maybe
you and I are others get from you know
more intimate relations with a spouse
and kids so on and on their compensation
you see something kind of similar in
monastic life where again hospitality
the rule of st. Benedict you know a lot
of discussion of hospitality in there
and it's very important but they live a
life that's you know pretty regimented
it's prayer and work and there's a lot
of time by oneself
which you know some of its supposed to
be used for prayer if it doesn't always
go that way and and in in a sense not
having all those you know like family
life and those connections opens up
one's capacity to when the guest comes
in to say oh hey so good to see you yeah
yeah absolutely
I think so you know Sunday on this
famous quote about how the marriage bed
and then you know an academic position
I'm just paraphrasing ordered like the
death of being a philosopher
there's no way professor well you're
doubly screwed up aren't you to this you
know I don't consider myself a
philosopher by any means I always
correct people in sama philosophy
scholar and teacher I consider your
flops and I appreciate that I appreciate
that someday I'll maybe write it down
more formally in a good judge of that
but but I mean there's some truth to
this you know that I think devoting
yourself to the life of the mind and so
on you know it can be very difficult
when you have kids and and so on but you
know that's an interesting discussion
John Locke's a famous scholar of
santiana has some good things to say
some interesting things to say along
these lines about contrasting duty and
santiana and how it was perhaps a blind
spot in santiana that he never had
family christmas matrix of connections
yeah so yeah but it's interesting he has
a great phrase he said santiana looks at
everything to reverse binoculars and
when he first he uses this gun zoom in
by that yeah he uses this phrase a lot
this is john locke's and when he first
said this to me in conversation I was
like I said the same thing yeah and then
I encountered it something you wrote and
something else ro so it's kind of a
refrain and what he means I think is
from a distance right from a great
distance
so whereas most of us sort of we look
out from where we are to try to get a
kind of big picture that's of things
something that starts from the big
picture and then has a hard time you
know zooms in and he's good at it but I
think it keeps the world at bay because
some degree keeps the world at arm's
length I think it probably kept people
at arm's like no question something that
was I mean if you wanted to
psychoanalyze him he certainly had some
issues with political engagement he was
criticized for his
miss on that on that in that regard he
was solicited at various times of his
life to be politically engaged and he
never we never fought through him that
he was he was like very worried that
stuff I mean he lived in Mussolini's
Italy and complemented the trains
running on time like new fathers did and
never really stressed too much about the
threat of fascism and which was scary
because he lived right through his two
world wars he was he was scarily aloof
from that stuff and also we should
mention anti-semitic I mean he has many
passages and his writings that
unfortunately bear the mark of their
time in terms of typical of people like
him who would have abused he had a
couple of Jewish the famous Jewish
students walter Lippmann and Horace
Kalin okay okay so and I wrote about
this recently which is why it's
something I know about but I doubt if
any of the viewers know him it was a
political scientist right yeah and had a
very public influence along the lines of
John Dewey John Dewey emblem and had a
famous kind of a series of debates about
the Great Society you know and and so he
was kind of a quasi elitist conservative
but not really a liberal yeah yeah I
mean it's sort of what led into the we
could say they're the ones who led into
like the Kennedy administration and the
you know gather all the great minds
their vocabularies it's striking how
much of Lippmann and do his vocabulary
ends up in political discourse in
various ways and living a particular but
some he was a Sousa influenced by
Santiago Lippmann and Sante I always
preferred Lippmann to Kalin Horace Kalin
what of because of his this is his
anti-semitism the first also I've been
working this out recent it's interesting
he he saw Lippmann as the good Jew and
he saw Kalin is kind of like the bad Jew
or those the the troubled you or
something he had he read his student
count his student Horace Cowan sent him
letters and said hey you know kind of
kind of wanted his old teacher to read
what he was writing he was writing about
a Zionist kind of development he was he
was all for kind of establishment
eventually of a Jewish state in one of
his writings and he's speaking very
openly about and I think very deeply too
I think
Kalin had a great insight into the
situation of the Jew in the first half
of the 20th century it of brilliant
insight into its santiana
criticized him he thought he was he
thought he was you know he uses all the
stereotypical kinds of criticisms that
people at that time who were
anti-semitic might use against Jews and
he did against him but whereas Littman
was sort of like the preferred Lippmann
because Lippmann was I guess more like
him or something or you know I could I
couldn't quite say but but it's an
interesting feature of you know the
larger picture of the the man santiana
Fischer yeah I mean so this is something
we talked about a little bit I mean
something Anna's not part of the wasp
the white anglo-saxon Saxon Protestant
establishment but he's also formed by it
to some extent right yeah absolutely
absolutely and I mean he never
relinquished his Spanish citizenship
he's buried and I've seen it in the
Spanish clock in Rome the only spent the
Spanish territory of plots for for the
gravesites in Rome we went on a rainy
Halloween night in Rome searching for
his grave and it was too dark we
couldn't hide so the next morning we
went and found it this is a wonderful
experience and a very good humble
looking thing it's not it's like tiny
little sort of memorial to Tucson Tianna
but he was buried there because he was
in Rome ultimately I think he wanted it
one time to leave Rome for sure but it
just became he became too old and he was
too established at the convent where he
was being taken care of but yeah he
never gave up his Spanish citizenship
partly because I mean I think obviously
because he never felt like he totally
belonged
yeah I mean he if he if he belonged
anywhere he was he was originally in
Spanish he was the Spaniard and there's
certainly commonalities speaking of
which between him and who knew mundo
Oh girls might know Miguel de Unamuno
who wrote the tragic sense of life yeah
one of my favorite short stories of all
time San Manuel way no martyr which is
got it's it's terribly untranslated
there's one poorly translated version
that you can google if you want but it's
made it's worth reading even poorly
translated it's a wonderful story
but it's very something on the like and
again very underdeveloped areas
scholarship would be to you know compare
and contrast you know the existentialist
was yeah I mean another Spanish
philosopher that comes to mind is Ortega
y Gasset
their connections between hemming and
something about are not that I could
speak very astutely about that there are
I think speaking of this very point
Spanish scholars I know of in
association with the Santana Society
which I'm proud to be associated with
over the years when we met for three
maybe four international conferences now
I use count because there's been enough
of them and there's a cohort of Spanish
scholars who want to kind of take
santiana up in the generation of 98 and
if listeners aren't familiar with that
that's a Spanish scholarship kind of
category for cassette you know and other
figures who constitute this generation
of 98 which is a flowering of
intellectual Spanish genius kind of
thing I thought that's my crude
understanding of them but they want to
take him up with somebody who belongs
largely not writing in Spanish was
actually and that's his fascinating
about so you have contemporary Spanish
scholars like your brothers right I mean
is it right to german philosopher or
american forces right because she once
she gets here she writes I think
exclusively in English right so it's
probably like something out of himself
would have been my generation of 98 but
I'm not joining any club like yeah but I
find it promising and interesting the
other fellows these great scholars and
you're when you when you post this
they're wherever you post this or if you
post this I think we can provide all
this information for interested persons
but this is an international development
there's a guy named Chris Skowronski who
is the kind of a head of all of this he
is a santiago scholar in poland from
poland a pull a university and he has
been the reason why all these scholars
have gotten together probably five times
now there's been I don't know how many I
shouldn't know but I know there's been
probably at least four International
Congress congress's on the thought of
Jorge Santiago well that's so that's a
good segue
into two things one is tell us more
about the the Sante Hana society and
then the other thing is you know we're
we're is he being read in particular and
studied in particular he comes up in
funny places santiana of scholarship
wise and he's there's people from poetic
from literary critical studies from
people who are scholars and writers of
poetry will show up but historians are
very interested in santiana and and then
of course philosophers but when we
gather with the Santana society which
has since the 80s has been meeting
annually at the American Philosophical
Association APA Eastern Division meeting
the Santana Society has a standing
session there since the eighties when we
gather there it's amazing that people
show you know one guy I know who became
a PhD under our old mentor Tom Alexander
SIU he was he's a retired social
security guy and I ended up end up going
on to spend all of Santi on his works
and decided he wanted to get a PhD I
mean this is the kind of person that we
we see coming out of the woodwork and
all the time and and coming from all
kinds of corners of life he's that kind
of a figure but the society is the only
formal apparatus in which there's kind
of like a collection of at least
stateside scholarship it was on ten
there's a journal - oh so sorry that's
called overheard in Seville and it is
the bulletin of the Santiago Society now
the title of it is interesting because
the bulletin of the Santiago society
right yeah its Angus Kerr Lawson who is
recently passed away was the longtime
curator and he was the source of his
origin of the actual bulletin I think it
was his intention to make sure it was
only a bulletin he didn't want this to
be a rival of what's called the
transactions transactions he didn't want
this to be something that pretended to
be rivaling anything that pretended to
be like a pure you know research one
kind of journal with that said over the
years it's been almost the sole source
of all the scholarship was to Conti on I
mean that's been the place that's
gathered it's the dope it's the
publication that gives most of the
scholarship that happens in Cynthiana
yeah sort of like Hobbes study
um studies or these other other journals
so but bulletin overheard in Seville
which is now so I was privileged to be
president after Glenn tiller was
president who was president after Angus
Kerr Lawson who passed away five years
ago and so Glen tiller than me and now
it is richard rubin and so we're taking
turns we seven or so American scholars
who say our time devoting ourselves to
the study and discussion of something I
was thinking I should mention Herman's
at camp for sure Herman's at camp has is
now retired he was recently a president
of a small College in New Jersey and he
retired from that but four years he was
John Locke student and he was the reason
why the critical edition which is now at
IUPUI under Martin Coleman always the
reason why that got underway and
eventually developed to where it is
Holtzberg or William Holtz Berger
recently died as well but he was the
colleague of sack camp and those are the
two main editors still of the the names
that are on the side of the volumes of
what are called the critical edition
books those are huge
of huge importance because well they're
critical editions which if listeners
don't know about those those are really
vital to scholarship based kind of
certify and give you every everything
you need to know about the history of a
particular work that an author wrote
usually heavily footnoted emendations
everything so that work is ongoing and
it's at IUPUI Indiana university-purdue
University Indianapolis yeah you have to
say that very carefully other way to get
it wrong and so conglomerate that's at
what's called the American Institute
that wrong but it's the name it's the
namesake of a collection of three major
figures who is it that's under this this
is fabric Douglass the Frederick
Douglass papers new yeah CS purse is
also there and then santiana and I think
I might be leaving one out but it's
under this American Institute
sontee Honor Society or something on
addition they'll get that next up
something an addition is connected with
that at IUPUI meantime the Santana
Society is a separate protects
supporters you could say but they
support each other the other connected
so yeah I hope that is somewhat
completely maybe the prospects you think
for both younger scholars you know
studying some ten isn't a new generation
and then you know broader appeal people
who aren't in academics to get into
Sunday you know funny you should ask
where that's exactly on the minds of the
current sort of society folks of which
I'm associated of course we recently had
several email exchanges where we're
coming up with all kinds of good ideas
to try to solicit younger scholars just
more innovative more social and
political philosophy types to write on
Santana which hasn't been the case in
the past so we have a variety of
strategies one of them is Angus Collison
we're honoring him in his life's work
with an award it's a yearly award three
hundred dollars I hope I have that right
before the award of the best essay on
Santi on a Pete there's a deadline so
what I hope we can provide all that
information at the end of this I think
yeah actually we certainly can and you
know it sounds like a very small award
but this is the sort of thing that for
like a budding scholar you would go onto
their CV and it'd be something that
people would take note this is the Angus
Kerr Lawson prize we call it and I think
it's only on its third year you know we
it's that recent but there's that
there's SAP the Society for the
Advancement of American philosophy and a
Pierre the two conferences that the
society kind of balances between it's
always at the APA but every three or
four years it doesn't always be that's
right no SAP has a kind of uh we've
tried to get it standing there run they
just can't accommodate because they have
mean there's Royce there's all the other
finger societies and unless they
accommodate every one of them they can't
you know so that what they do instead is
they kind of invite each intern okay and
and it's great that they do and and when
they do some great things come of that
and we tried the central APA for awhile
but that wasn't as successful as
and ER attendant I think these bigger
conferences are starting to get more
under attended as you know things happen
in academia but yeah but we're trying
that's a topic we could we could talk
about
well relate to this wonderful endeavor
that you're doing Greg oh you're about
the modern stoicism and stoicism today
we're listening to this and be a
videoing we are going to this is richard
rubin who is now the president's of
today just say richard rubin tsa yes
getting that right I'm really fuzzy
brain Greta we are developing so we can
do like some kind of webcast or
something like that for for one of the
major conferences and in fact I'll give
you the information but then the next
maybe that I think it's the first one I
may have missed another one but I think
it is the first official one is gonna
happen in a couple of months I want to
say and I'll give you the information
but yeah there's so much potential for
connecting people who can't make it to
these these you know central conferences
the streaming and it's really being
under under explored this is one of my
sort of soapbox issues because you know
I'm involved with the modern stone so
some people really great at that sort of
thing
Aristotelian not so much you know I've
suggested to the International Society
for MacIntyre and inquiry year after
year after year you need to start doing
some some connection because it's an
International Society for people who
can't make it to France or can't make it
to wherever you happen to be holding the
thing you should have some video
sessions right record some of the
sessions and have the membership you
know login and and talk about what's
going on and answer a few questions and
then and then have host a few panels
where it's actually being done by by
spected be so easy to do and you get so
much either indifference or resistance
from traditional academics about that
the people who get and of course are the
people in business or in other fields so
and I also wonder how much they're I
know the APA is not alone in this but
they've recently been somewhat in crisis
they've been sending yeah a lot of
emails about you know
support the APA they're losing money and
they are for all the reasons that
academia itself as well I'm not a member
I mean the only time that I've ever like
paid membership dues is when I needed to
go there to interview for conferences
and it wasn't in large part because I
saw the APA as embodying three things I
didn't like one was it was dominated by
analytic philosophy the other thing it
was dominated by elitist institutions
and the third thing was that it endorsed
all sorts of you know political stances
that I you know some of which I could
get behind some of which I couldn't
tonight yeah I saw I think a lot of
academics see the APA just as a
necessary evil that we had to put up
with and so we've got kind of a bad
taste in it they aren't trying to retool
ya pretty I automatically have some
mixed feelings about myself I feel like
on the one hand I feel guilty part of
myself says you know I definitely owe
some loyalty to things like the a Pierre
the percept but I don't know Sam I think
you owe more to ya you know I have no
problem you know sort of supporting
these these smaller more local things
but when it comes to the APA yeah you
know they would really have to be doing
a lot for me to think that I owe them
well relative to the Santi on a society
I it's one of the things going forward
now that we're sort of moving to this
new sort of ero and phase yeah do we
want to continue to have those standing
society meetings at the Eastern forum
we've thought we flirted with the idea
of moving to the central but again we've
kind of struck out doing that it would
be ideal maybe to just do SAP but again
we can do that yeah so it's a tricky
thing you know it's really tricky yeah I
mean this may sound like a bit of an
arcane topic for some of our viewers but
these these I think it's important to
point out of that a lot of philosophical
exchange happens through two main means
one is through journals and
you know publications that go on in
those but a lot of that happens through
conferences I know when I was teaching
at Indiana State Prison because I was
the only person other than one other guy
part-time doing philosophy at the prison
conferences were a lifeline for me that
would go I mean you're in a small
department here where you know you have
to be up some good colleagues in other
other areas but you only have one other
full-time philosopher right so
conferences are we where we academics
can exchange ideas can find out what's
going on proposed collaborations you
know yet those are very important for
academic life yeah and I I feel bad when
I miss one you know one fully uh I don't
think I've gone a full year recently but
if I ever have to miss a conference it's
I feel like I'm at the time you know I'm
not a connection and yeah I get that
connection and it's it's vital I think
to the furtherance of what we're doing I
mean you know santiana is an example of
a figure that I consider him readable
for centuries to come and I think he's
one of those great yeah so this goes
back to the question of like you know
readership of Santa Ana outside of
academia what do you see the prospects
it's a it's already good and I think
that's one of the things that sustained
strangely the santiana interest over the
years is that people from various
outside of philosophy quarters are
engaging with santiana and if you just
peruse the last say ten editions of the
bulletin you would find people from over
an array of backgrounds you know
classics certainly history and critical
theory or literary studies are certainly
just you think you think it has
something to say to people who aren't in
academics at all but might be you know
working in an office or are retired or
you know you know from different walks
of life I think so it's difficult unless
you have I mean have to you still have
to have a broad interest in the history
of philosophy as the supposed to catch
with santiana is that he is so steeped
in the history philosophy that you're
very quick and easy to lose your
foothold if you're not
yeah his references and so on but that
said no I think he oh yeah I mean
there's a book called dialogues in limbo
maybe that's ahead of my mind when I
misspoke earlier but that is a
wonderfully creative book the book is
nothing more than it's a it's a
recreated dialogue where he's working
out his ideas but in the guise of
there's a stranger having a conversation
with some of the great great figures in
the history of philosophy and and it's
wonderful because it's written like a
platonic dialogue and it's I think
anybody can engage with it and I think
yeah fine but we really recommend that
one particular dialogue called normal
madness if you were going to read one of
them that would be called normal madness
it's a wonderful thing ya know that kind
of reminds me of what it is that that
Socrates threatens he's gonna do in the
apology you know you can kill me but
then I'm gonna go down to Hades and then
you're not gonna be able to shut me up
and nobody's gonna stop my mouth and I'm
gonna cross and examine all these great
heroes that you've got and just wait you
know you guys until you die you come
down there you know what it's very
possible something I only had that
passage in mind when you came up with
this concept I'm not sure but it's a
very creative cop I mean he's yeah he
sucked it was kind of you know what I
would say there's this quip about
Emerson
rather about the James brothers I should
say the James brothers Henry and William
James yes you know William James wrote
philosophy like a literary figure and
Henry James wrote literature like
philosophy yeah to whatever extent
that's true
santino like Emerson yeah is you know
philosophy in a literary way and while
that's off-putting to people who want
you know straight philosophy just give
me the arguments yeah what is your
argument and yeah what does that stop I
mean I had a teacher and graduate
mastered my master's program who who
said there's no point in reading Plato
or any of the historical figures because
you know their arguments amount to three
by five cards you know you have that
narrow of a view and it's that view that
it's you know and I don't think that's
gonna die anytime soon in part because
it's not as if analytic philosophy is
going to go away
become it's kind of lost its its
original you know projects and and it's
back history but it's become certain to
facto so I think for a lot of people
that's what it is and then the internet
also does promote a whole cross-section
of people who are not doing analytic
philosophy but they are arguing and they
are interpreting in an analytic way
they're like what's the argument with
the premises you know and that's it and
they they they these these are people
who you know sometimes that's all
they've really had and some people are
so I think temperamental II and driven
towards that but they're missing out on
so much more because the history of
philosophy
throughout its history is you know we
both know has has philosophy has been
not a separate isolated thing but
something that had connections with
history with religion with literature
with all these other I mean even you
mentioned architecture all these other
fields and it benefits so much when
that's the way philosophy is being done
it's Messier but I think that for the
the ordinary person it's it's also much
more interesting and much more
attractive yeah I get students all the
time who wouldn't read Plato or somebody
like him and it's not necessarily Plato
but somebody who writes in a
non-traditional or an expected way yeah
what they've come to expect philosophy
to be they're very surprised or like wow
I didn't know philosophy could be like
this you know and that's the thing that
people who are very narrow that's the
unfortunate aspect we use you know when
you look at philosophy only in terms of
argument but your point is well placed
it's a sensibility I mean you said it
earlier you know the the analytic
sensibility and the Continental
so-called sense of sensibility will
always be there yeah whatever we call it
it's kind of a divide I suppose and the
MA in the human you know let me see you
know history of philosophy as assertive
tertium quid between analytic and
continental yes or maybe with a bit more
in common with continental philosophy
but you know if you're if you're doing
history a philosophy like if you're
studying say Plato will you read all of
Plato you don't just read you know a few
texts
or you read at least as much as you can
that's that's why you know maybe pick a
figure it was a little bit more
manageable hairy frog Fernandez si said
that the reason he became a Descartes
scholar was because Descartes corpus was
was small enough that he he was he felt
himself to be lazy and that would be
easy for injury that's very honest yeah
but I think there's something there it's
not necessarily it's all about locating
them in their historical place and we
don't do a sort of historical
reductionism where we say well they're
just a product other times but you get
so much more I mean let's return to
suntan you get so much more out of
understanding who Santa Ana is and what
he's saying by knowing about the you
know turn-of-the-century
America and what Europe was like at the
time and and the situation that he was
formed in and all of that yeah yeah yeah
absolutely it's funny you say that
because I when I got my PhD in 2003 I
was employed thereafter in 2004 I spent
I've spent really the remainder of the
time in between my teaching duties and
so on kind of filling in the gaps of the
period of time a philosophy that I
profess to be an expert in and part of
that is reading all the literature in
the background of it you know this is a
great topic yeah yeah there's so many we
call them validates rabbit holes that
open up every yeah everything you
research there's another conversation
that you could follow up further so how
do you manage that it's very hard you
have to be reading all the time I mean
my bedtime reading right now is Thomas
Hardy's Jude the Obscure just because
it's a book that I haven't read and I
and I passed the reference somewhere and
thought oh I'd better fill in that gap
and I'm loving it I'm enjoying it but
it's it never ends because you know yeah
I mean take historical period that I'm
interested in which is roughly you know
1850 to 1950
it's just layer upon layer upon layer
upon layer and you're never going to and
you're never going to complete your
understanding of that
the time but you find how ignorant you
are the more you know as they say is the
saying goes and that's that's one of the
things I've enjoyed about having a
career in education and anybody who is
interested in it is that the attraction
of it is you learn how how important it
is to be humble and to figure out how
little you know and and then to be
remain hungry for knowing more you know
that's what I do I think you should just
and you shouldn't only read philosophy
you shouldn't only read literature
either I mean people in literary studies
soon won't go near philosophy you know
and that's not a good thing you know
when I was in SIU you know we had a lot
of connections between the philosophy
graduate students I don't know if this
happened with the undergrads but
philosophy graduate students had a lot
of connections with people in the
English department yeah and also speech
comm and a few other areas as well and I
remember being struck when I when I went
to like dinner parties or just regular
parties and we'd have conversations and
they bring up they bring up authors and
it wasn't you know it wasn't so much
talking about you know philosophical
authors talk about literary authors they
wouldn't like us philosophers because it
wasn't so much about argument it was
more about evidence yeah they put forth
a proposal about this is what's going on
and this this piece right here and it
could be about a movie here could be
about some some you know work of
literature and then the philosophers
would say things like well that's an
interesting interpretation but here's
why I think you know it's not really
supported and here's here's an
interpretation that maybe other things
in the text and support and their jaws
would just drop and and you know you got
the idea that we were showing bad
manners there right and you know if you
just shut up and listen to them what
you'd hear instead was you know here's
an interpretation oh that's really
interesting and have you thought about
this and thought about this and and it
would never be that sort of critical
moment of now I think you're wrong about
that
and that's that's important I know I
don't think it's only analytic
philosophers who can do that I think
there's something about the field of
philosophy that does tend to promote
that critical positions taking critical
positions related to what you're saying
I
you have a colleague various colleagues
across campus but one in particular
comes to mind he's in sociology and one
time he was making fun of somebody in I
think it was maybe psychology apartment
they were kind of quitting back and
forth good sparring a little bit yeah
and he said something like well we do is
you know we we do the same thing you do
only we do it with evidence but I kept
all the fighting words yeah exactly like
with evidence yeah I remember thinking
well yeah sociology you know right then
my prejudice is so we all kind of you
know all I my view is I think all these
disciplines are really great and
important and obviously they make their
own unique contributions but we all have
our sort of biases and I'm an
interdisciplinary person I feel like all
these things well you know so this is a
good place to bring things to close both
in terms of Cynthiana and in terms of
philosophy I haven't seen one of the big
differences is that in the 20th century
philosophy philosophy kind of shrunk in
in terms of its in school in analytic
philosophy and also in continental
philosophy and then of course some
people in history philosophy cuz I'm
just a specialist I only like look at
wide Nets and it's thought about this or
that well well it won't happen at leas
and and so i don't see that in in some
of the 20th century figures that I'm
really interested in like say God real
Marcel or Maurice Bloom know and they
they think that philosophy in principle
extends to everything but unlike say
Hegel who thinks that that philosophy
not only extends to everything but can
like digest it and tell everybody else
where they fit in they think that
philosophy has to do a lot of work to
manage to adapt itself so philosophy
wants to look at religion it can't just
like you know preach down to religion it
has to actually like take take away what
religious claims are seriously this is
what's wrong with so much of a
philosophy of religion do you think
there's something like that especially
when we think about Santa Anas later
works you know where he is
doing that all this very deep and
metaphysical work that has a similar
presupposition about the nature of
philosophy to it that philosophy is in
principle about everything and if it's
not trying to talk about the totality
it's it's failings and in some way as
philosophy I think so and that's in fact
one of the sticking points between
santiana and Dewey who was santiana
claimed we didn't have a cosmology that
was a phrase he used he has no cosmology
and maybe not the best term or phrase
and one that he didn't necessarily
unpack correctly but I took him to mean
something along these lines that that
Dewey didn't there was no sense of the
totality there was no sense of you know
he wasn't seeing the office of
philosophy as you know as to tell us
about the totality in some way and now I
think yeah I think santiana is certainly
to be counted among those in the history
of philosophy who see philosophy as
explaining everything I mean what else
what good would it do if you didn't set
out to basically explain everything now
that's that's putting it one way Sanjay
I never pretended to explain everything
in that sense and that very phrase
suggests a kind of you know narrow and a
narrower thing that it showed - you
mentioned scientism earlier the idea
that we can explain everything from the
standpoint of science yeah that's what I
could take scientific to be something
you know philosophers who set out to
explain everything don't necessarily say
I can only explain it from the
standpoint of philosophy right what they
do is they say Heidegger is a good
example of this you know what is being
right I mean that very question is yeah
if it doesn't open up everything you
know then then what else would it do and
is it a philosophical question I take it
to be but maybe it's not only that and
so so it's a tricky thing isn't it like
I think the floss was like Heidegger and
santiana I see a lot of kinships between
them in this regard that they see you
know they think ontologically it starts
with being and what is the question of
the meaning of being society right and
that would be you know if that if that
if everything else doesn't follow from
that then I'm not sure you know that I'm
not sure what we mean by that you know I
mean it's philosophy is it ought to be
it ought to explain everything in that
sense I guess is what I'm trying to say
or at least take a stand better take a
stab at it and it's a better way of
putting it and there's a great phrase
you know CS purse talks about it in
terms of a guess at the riddle you know
and I think philosophy is at its best
when it's speculative and yeah the
opening chapter to whiteheads process
and reality has always been influential
on me he has that it's called
speculative philosophy and it's
beautiful commentary there on you know
speculation is vital and inspect in a
meaning speculation for the sake of
speculation we don't necessarily have to
know we're right speculation is
absolutely vital and maybe the only way
we can get it you know what this riddle
of existence is and yeah I love that
sentiment because that's what philosophy
is when it said it's best to me it's
it's most humble and it's least arrogant
you know
yeah well that's great clothes for the
conversation thanks hope so very much
for offering your expertise and
experience well thank you yeah yeah no
you're you're doing a great thing with
these ongoing videos you're doing and
tutorials I think it's an amazing
service to the layperson and beyond so
oh thanks thank you sir
you